you
how's everyone doing how many of you are
here for the first time Wow okay great
well this is my third time here so I'm
like Lessing all of it all of this but I
hope you're enjoying this and super
grateful for everyone to be here today
so I'm going to be giving you another
State of the Union so it's being a quite
interesting year as you know we've been
working really hard on 3.0 and we're
going to go over some of the things that
went through it what we did and why it
took so long and well let's get right
into it so the bulk of them 2019 was
spent on pushing v3 from a research and
prototyping stage into reality and we're
really close so I remember last year
when I was here I was essentially
talking about we just started working on
v3 we've made a prototype we've got some
ideas we're trying to validate them and
today I'm happy to say we're pretty much
achieved most of the goals that we set
out to achieve of u3 so the work left
now really is trying to polishing it up
make it stable and getting everything
ready for release in the meanwhile let's
take a moment just like look at the
stats which is what I do almost every
year for this we're currently at over
1.1 million weekly active users for the
vgs dev tools so the dev tools is the
metrics that i personally use to get a
relatively accurate idea of how many our
our general user growth this is probably
does not reflect all the users we
probably have more because some users
probably don't use the dev tools but i
personally find this to be a relatively
more accurate metrics then say github
stars or NPM downloads which just have
too many variants to be considered so
a short graph showing our growth from
2017 to 2022 NT 17 mostly because we
only publish the dev tools in late 2016
so really steady growth and MPM
downloads shown the same trend compared
to January 2019 that is probably
approximately the same time last year
we've seen 1.7 X growth on NPM dollars
as well so interestingly we didn't
actually do big releases for two point X
for the entirety of 2019 but we're still
seeing really decent growth so I think
that's a good sign showing that to fall
next is really a stable and serving its
purpose and that really gives us you
know allowed us to focus on 3.0 and
getting it ready so state of j/s survey
2018 versus 2019 said satisfaction rate
didn't really change much but we can see
the the red part the red part is the
people who've used and will use again so
this total red part is people who've
used it and these are people who have
not used it and the gray part which
disappeared pretty much disappeared is
people who've never heard about VJs so
that's a good thing
Stack Overflow survey 2019 so view is
among some of the most beloved tools
that developers use and interestingly we
were not even in the survey in 2018
so another good sign okay so let's talk
about the journey to v3 so it took a
really long time for us to get to where
we are today a lot of hard work went
into it and so I want to sort of take a
step back and just look at what we what
really made the journey so long and some
of the thought process that went into it
so I divided it into
stages the stage stage one starting in
late 2018 which is when we first started
the idea of maybe we should consider a
new major version to just laying out the
foundation for a new repository trying
out some of the things that we wanted to
do so that was stage one that is the
early foundation experimentation stage
what we did during this stage first we
made the decision to use typescript
for the new repository we used to flow
into point X and it's being serving us
well for a decent amount of time but
Facebook just never just never want to
release 1.0 so it keeps releasing
breaking changes or minor releases and
it's getting a bit of it's becoming kind
of a chore to upgrade flow and the code
base itself it was aging all right so
we've long had ideas of a better
structure in the internals so we moved
to our mono repo architecture if you
look at the view next repo now you'll
notice we divide these internals into
compilers runtimes we even split out the
reactivity into its own package we also
use layer design where we have the
compiler core which is platform agnostic
then we have the compiler the Dom
targeting compiler server-side rendering
targeting compiler built on top of it we
have a new testing setup using just
replacing some some of the more flaky
parts with with the test suite that just
runs faster and more stable refined
workflow scripts and establish the RFC
process so most of these work in the
early stages doing the app here at a
time didn't really bring out any say new
features or exciting stuff for the end
users but these these were actually
important work that laid the foundation
for us to do further work on top of this
so then in early 2019 we got the first
we essentially got the first prototype
which has basic
feature completed so you can actually
start an application render some
components and have state updates so we
completed a reactivity module we
completed a runtime virtual Dom renderer
right but around that time we so I
consider that time to be the completion
of the first stage so we have the new
architecture the new foundation and we
have a basic prototype working but and
then we started to seriously think about
what do we really want in v3 that's the
end user affecting new features new big
improvements and that took quite a bit
of time for us to just stop and think
about these major new ideas we want to
rethink the runtime update strategy
right the view 3 prototype was fast we
had early early benchmarks that showed
it was faster than u2 but it was just
not fast enough if we are doing a new
major version we could do better right
so in stage 2 spent I spent a lot of
time just researching different
rendering strategies trying to find sort
of a more fundamental improvement in
terms of dating rendering Stren during
performance and then we were also
iterating on the new API right in the
early stage we proposed a class API
trying to offer a better way to use view
with typescript but as you all know now
the class API didn't really turn out to
give us what we want it it just didn't
get provide enough and it has its own
fair share of problems mostly related to
how the class API is built on top of its
its dependency its reliance on a lot of
these new native yes Eknath script
features which were not really stable at
that point right class itself is already
in ES 2015 however we
have a lot of features like class fields
decorators which are still not even in
the spec right now they're still stage 2
or stage 3 so so we did class API and at
the same time we came up with a idea of
a function API inspired by rack hooks
and which took quite a bit of time for
us to iterate on and try to refine and
many of you probably remember the the
the little upset from the community when
we first published the draft of the
function API many people thought we're
going to essentially pull in an angular
2 and release a version that is
incompatible and we realized ok we're
phrasing was probably wrong and that was
not what we intended to do so we
reworked the whole composition API RFC
to better present what it really is as
which is a purely additive layer on top
of the API you're used to and really
trying to go from more fundamental
concepts explaining where the
composition API comes from and how it
compliments the way we're doing it today
so so let's just dig a bit deeper into
the runtime update strategy improvements
I've talked about this a few times
backing 2019 but I think probably some
of you here are not fully we have not
really seen the details of what what I
meant by a faster runtime updating
strategy so the basic idea is the unique
advantage of view as a framework
compared to other rendering strategies
so we have two a spectrum of different
rendering strategies so if we take one
extreme say react react is based on the
virtual Dom and is extremely dynamic and
then we have the other at the end of the
strep spectrum purely template based
actually angular spelt embers they all
kind of fall into this category
they require you to write the template
they compile the template into something
that's efficient for updates but you can
only write templates so once the
template is compounded it becomes kind
of a black box there's no way for you to
bypass the template layer and directly
work at the renderer level well for
react it's really flexible you directly
work with the virtual Dom you can write
your own render functions manipulate and
it's pure JavaScript however it doesn't
give you this compilation well you do
have JSX and polishing but it's still
too dynamic it doesn't give you this
opportunity to have a static template
that is very easy to analyze and
optimize so view has this unique
combination of where we do have
templates we compile templates into
virtual Dom render functions so
underneath we have virtual Dom but on
top of it we present it's via a template
layer so this gives us the unique
position to leverage both the dynamic
power of virtual Dom we can expose the
render function API for advanced users
library authors who require the extreme
flexibility of JavaScript at the same
time when you use template we can
leverage the template to do static
analysis and perform and produce
JavaScript code that's more optimized
than what you would produce with
manually written render functions so the
bottleneck of the traditional virtual
Dom updating strategy is it's that it's
very brute force right suppose we have a
template like this with a single binding
in the template what but the virtual Dom
update would do is it would recursively
walk the whole tree of these nodes and
compare every single one of them
regardless of whether it's changed or
not and then it only when it walks onto
this node it will figure out ok there's
it's text content change so I need to
perform an update so on the right we see
the whole list of operations that the
virtual Dom algorithm would need to
perform especially when you have another
bottleneck
another overhead here is as we can see a
lot of these elements they have static
attributes right technically you don't
even need to care about these static
attributes once they are rendered
however in a virtual Dom implementation
these attributes are props passed to the
the V node right so when the virtual Dom
different algorithm sees an element with
props
it doesn't really know whether the props
have changed so it have to do a full
object property iteration on the props
object compare each of the props to see
whether they have changed another layer
of overhead right so having a template
compliation step in fact give us the
opportunity to optimize away these
unnecessary work and this is what we're
doing in the view 3 compiler by
analyzing the template and breaking them
into so what we call blocks so the
blocks are segments of your template
that is divided by structural directives
what we essentially V if and v 4 so V if
and V 4 are the only directives that
allows you to manipulate the tree
structure of your template so without vs
than V 4 we can consider your template
to have a very to have a stable stable
tree structure so which means we don't
need to actually walk the tree if we
know the structure is stable the only
thing we need to do is to keep track of
the dynamic nodes inside a stable block
so I'm not digging into too much details
here I have passed talks on the on the
internet if you are interesting
researching more details on the
compliation strategy but here the
high-level idea is by dividing our
templates into these blocks divided by
these structural directives we we divide
a whole template into a few blocks each
template will become maybe three to four
blocks depending how many V if and V
force you have and then within each
block it has a stable tree structure
which means we can track all the dynamic
bindings like class bindings text
findings and all these dynamic bindings
in a flat array so each block contains
only one flat array of dynamic nose that
needs to be updated so we've essentially
changed our template updating efficiency
from from work that scales with the size
of the template to work that scales
directly with the number of dynamic
bindings inside your template right so
this was one of the weakness of virtual
Dom is that even when you have only very
small number of dynamic bindings it
still need to do a huge amount of work
to reconcile reconcile the updates so
with views new compliation strategy if
you have only one dynamic binding that's
all the work that's need to do all we
need to do to update the template so
this was the fundamental improvement in
terms of performance that we we're
shipping in view 3 and so this is a
spreadsheet that I made for the internal
comparison with view 2 so this count
this row is probably the one that will
be most relevant to you this is
improvement overview 2 with template
compilation and no with no with means we
are stripping we're stripping the the
width block inside a compilation output
so this is internal details but the
general idea is if you're using in
browser compliation you'll be seeing
whoops you'll be looking at this column
but if you're using UCI or single file
components with the pre-compiled
templates you're looking at this column
so mount performance 51 percent average
update performance is 133 percent better
and this is with reactivity included
right so without reactivity just look at
the raw algorithm improvements we're
seeing over 200 % improvements in terms
of raw algorithmic improvements so but
this this is a this is a benchmark
that's based on up
eating a huge list items each item has a
fare typical mix of static versus
dynamic content so you probably will
have 15 stable static elements and four
to five dynamic elements inside the each
block so which should be pretty
representational for the average type of
components you would author in a typical
application okay so so that was stage 2
stage 2 we really try to nail like the
major improvements that we want to land
in view 3 and we achieved that and so
this was the performance part and
another part big part of it obviously is
composition API which we won't have
plenty of talks on about so I won't be
digging too much into it now
so stage 3 late 2019 until now really
because we validated most of the idea so
the work left is trying to push view 3
towards feature completion and as you
can see I've been working pretty hard
we're finalizing a lot of our SCS we
merged a number of our rfcs if you look
at the RFC repo now we have I think 19
RFC is merged so if you are asking
what's kind of changing view 3 how do i
migrate we will have an official you
know easier to digest migration guide
obviously which we're working on but if
you are eager you're curious you want to
know it now just go to the RFC repo look
at the merged RFC's each of the ifc
discusses the migration of the adoption
strategy so you can kind of evaluate how
much this RFC would actually affect you
so if you see the ax dot in the adoption
strategy you will typically see that
like something like oh this feature is
we can prove we can provide a compatible
layer for this feature or we can provide
a codemod to help you automatically
upgrade so those are the things you
should be looking for another major part
of work is finishing the new compiler so
we'll talk a bit more about the new
compiler in a minute and then service
our rendering which we'll also be
talking about so current status of u3 we
just released 3.0 0.0045 we have basic
runtime and compiler feature parity with
2.0 X this includes all the things like
V motto transition keep alive so most of
the features in view 2 you can find any
of you 3 now most active RFC is
implemented if you see an RFC is
probably in view 3 and so we incur so at
this stage we encourage you to just
start playing around with it and help us
identify bugs and behavior
inconsistencies with view to the basic
idea is that if you find something
that's not what you expected it works
differently from view to first thing you
do is you check the RFC's to see if this
is an intended change that we have
explicitly talked about in our FCS and
if not then it's probably unintended and
you should file a bug and we'll look
into it
so in r45 we also shipped basic
server-side rendering support so this
should be a good news for knucks users
and we're really close to beta because
the last piece of the the server-side
render was pretty much the last piece of
the puzzle that we need to complete
before we can call it actually feature
complete now the new compiler some of
the major improvements we have full
source map support the new compiler can
actually pinpoint an error in your
expression back to the part the
corresponding part in your template we
have a new plugin base transform
pipeline so this improved architecture
makes the compiler itself much more
maintainable so if you crack open the
source code you'll see the if is inside
its own transform file v4 is inside its
own transform file each directive is
managed and in you know transform
plug-in so if you are trying to help us
fix a bug it makes it much easier to
just find the right place to submit the
fix a layered design for higher order
compilers now we have a compiler core
which exposes these lower-level
utilities like base parts based
transform and base cogent and then it
also exports a lot of these internal
transforms so you can build your own
compiler on top of it if you want to and
the best example if you want to do that
the best example to look at is compiler
Dom which is our Dom targeting compiler
so if you if you look at the compiler
Dom its imports the base compilers
compile function and overrides a few
number of the transforms say we have a
base v-model transform which is platform
agnostic and the Dom compiler can
override the v-model transform to inject
additional steps that handles Dom
specific work like injecting the runtime
directive or handling modifiers that
only works that only makes sense in a
browser etc so we also built on top of
the core compiler to build our service
our rendering compiler which we'll talk
about in a moment
so the new compiler ships with a number
of advanced optimizations which were not
presenting view to the block based on a
map our tracking is what we talked about
that offers us the major performance
breakthrough in terms of updates and
then we have more aggressive static tree
hoisting we already do this in view too
but view choose render algorithm was not
designed with reusable nodes in mind so
there were a bunch of hacks that we had
to do and eventually there are too many
a lot of cases that we just simply have
to bail for static tree hosting which
made it less useful but in view 3 our
new algorithm just was designed with
reusable V nodes in mind from the ground
up so sad free hosting
becomes much easier to implement in the
compiler so we'll see some example of
this and then we have then handler
caching and stable slots detection so
this may look very abstract so I think
the best way to do it is crack open this
template Explorer so this is publicly
available at a few max template Explorer
dotnet Wi-Fi calm and it's automatically
deployed deployed against a current
master branch of view next and yeah so
let's see basic idea
let me tick off server-side rendering
and right so this is a basic template
that's being compiled I hope you can see
this so this just simply returns a
string obviously now let's turn it into
a div and now you see the open block
create block thing so open block create
block is the optimization that we talked
about and every template if it has
content then it has to be a block in
itself now if we add nested content into
this
as you can see this span is static so
it's being hoisted here if we wrap it
with more content now you can see the
whole div being hoisted here and your
render function simply reduce the
hoisted nodes every time it renders it's
just reusing the same node and when the
weather when the renderer algorithm try
to diff the two trees
it'll notice that this node is actually
hoisted so there's no work to be done
here just skip the tree and move on so
this would work for arbitrarily complex
structure as long as static we even
detect constant expressions so we know
this 1+1 is constant so it's hoist table
it doesn't depend on any scope variables
so even if it's a binding we still
hosted some of the more interesting
parts is if we copy this long enough we
notice that oh ok like this is a big
chunk of static content and it has a lot
of nodes a lot of nested nodes in fact
so how about let's just turn it into a
big chunk of string and just set in HTML
instead of creating a bunch of
JavaScript objects and walk them in
programmatically insert them into the
DOM write interesting optimizations here
so there are some heuristics that we use
to determine whether we should do this
because based on benchmarking this is
only faster if you do have a certain
number of nodes or complex enough static
tree so for simple structures like this
just do it just like mounting them one
by one is actually faster so we do a lot
of benchmarking to figure out what is
the best output most optimized output
you we would get and what's the other
thing that we talked about handler
hoisting yes so if we have a handler
click
right without hoisting without a handler
Cashman you see that this gets compiled
like unclick CTX hello and then we have
a patch flag which indicates that this
node for this node we need to patch its
props we don't need to care about
anything else and the only props that
you need to patch is on click because
that's the only thing that may change as
you can see if I add a static attribute
here we do have this included in the
props however I D because it static is
not listed as a dynamic prop so we don't
need to care about it so the only
dynamic probably care about is on click
and because it has its patch flag it
makes this node trackable inside the
current block so this div will be
tracked as a dynamic node in its parent
block right now what the hand what the
handler kashin does is if we turn this
on we notice that we are doing this
weird thing here so this what this
expression does is we initialize the
handler once and we dynamically access
the the actual method to call inside
this inline function and then we catch
this inline function for future updates
so on every so after the initial render
we create this function in cache it on
every subsequent render we are just
reusing the same handler so that notice
that the patch flag is gone which means
this node no longer have any dynamic
attributes dynamic props to diff against
so this actually means it's going to be
skipped during the updates right so this
essentially we're making all event
handlers optimizable so we don't need to
even dip it so this also applies for
components say if you have a component
right so previously in view to if you
have an event handler on a component and
especially for this right if you have an
inline handler something like this or
test123 right
this causes it to create a new inline
handler on every renderer so a common
problem in react is like when they use
hooks and you have an inline handler you
pass it to a child component because
you're creating a new function on every
render it will essentially make this
component always update when it's parent
updates right so it creates a lot of
cascading updates which is very
inefficient now with views handler
caching here we're cashing this inline
function like this so when this parent
componentry renders this child component
will never update because it just
doesn't receive any new props okay so a
lot of these minor details that goes
into the compiler implementation to make
your application run as fast as possible
and finally let's go into server-side
rendering okay so this was the last
piece of the puzzle so pretty distinct
view to so let's go a bit back of our
service our rendering so when react did
their service our rendering the most
obvious thing to do is render an
application into the virtual Dom
snapshot and then walk the virtual Dom
tree and serialize everything and turns
out it's obviously slow compared to
traditional pure string concatenation
templating strategies because you're
allocating a lot of objects then you're
walking these objects and then trying to
see realized on the integrated string
now view 2 has a special server side
rendering optimization compiler compiler
that compiles your template into
something different so if we go back to
template Explorer
this is the view to template Explorer
have you turned into a server render we
notice it creates something like this
okay so we are we are still rendering it
as a virtual Dom tree however we turn
some parts of the virtual Dom tree into
something we caught an SSR node in the
SSR node is a node that contains the
string representation of this node
inside here something like this
all right so we concatenate some of this
however there are a lot of places that
we have to bail mostly due to how the
view to compiler architecture was
somewhat too simple so that it doesn't
give us the enough tools to do proper
analysis to to to figure out in what
cases we we can still maybe optimize it
instead of bailing now in view 3 if we
put the same template into it and we
turn on server-side rendering and you
notice it's just a single call poulsen
pushing a plain string concatenation so
essentially no matter whatever kind of
bindings you have as long as you don't
have components in your template it's
just going to be a single giant string
concatenation call right so this makes
few three server-side rendering
extremely fast in fact we're seeing
three times faster performance compared
to view two and this will be practical
practically free as long as you use
templates so let's say next upgrades to
view three and your app will just render
three times as fast on the server okay
so some of the more interesting stuff we
can look at for the server-side
rendering is if you have a compiler if
you have a component inside your app
here so this component will break up
your let's do this so it's easier to see
what's going on so we have a plain
element here we have a component here
and we have another plain element here
now the challenge here is if your whole
services are entering call is
synchronous it would be really easy you
just push them sequentially right
however the challenge is we want to be
able to handle a
synchronicity in server-side rendering
for example a component in view 3 can
have an async setup function inside
async set of function you can pretty
much do anything async you may be
fetching data you may be fetching
another component you may be maybe
calling to a cache to cache the render
result right so there's a lot of things
you can do in the async hook and it's
just which means any component when you
compiling current component any child
component can potentially contain async
work so how do you resolve that as you
can see we're still just synchronously
pushing stuff here however what we're
pushing here by calling SS our render
component call here is in fact some
something we call a buffer right so a
component call render call inside
surface and rendering returns a buffer
which will which is essentially an array
of strings and promises so you can await
on that buffer to wait for it to resolve
so every component call as you can see
this is in fact recursive because this
is a component itself and what is
rendering is a list a buffer containing
some strings a buffer of a child
components and some more strings so we
so once you when you call render to
string you actually end up with a huge
nested buffer tree with parallel
asynchronous requests contained inside
of it and then at the top we do a single
a way to wait for all of them to resolve
and then put all the strings back
together
so what this gives us so this is a new
compilation strategy what the render new
renderer gives us is we can use async
set up to serve as a generic hook for
async work during service our rendering
you can use it to fetch data to code
splitting cache in anything you want
it's all handled under the same a
synchro mechanism and it offers you
maximally paralyze async rendering so
let's say you have a list of a thousand
items each of them are performing some
async work the new rendering strategy
will in fact render all of these at the
same time it'll dispatch all these async
request at the same time and wait for
them to all finish and then give you
back the final string right and also
seamlessly support mixing template and
render function based components which
means let's say you are writing a
template and then you use a view to Phi
component few different components are
written with render functions but you
can use them inks are templates render
functions in the same app you know
templates based components you can mix
and match them in the same app and the
renderer just handled them at just fine
the renderer automatically fallbacks to
virtual Dom based serialization when it
runs to such components so you get the
performance benefits when you write
templates but you don't have to Bill you
don't have to say manually switch back
and forth back and forth in order to
leverage render functions you can just
use them if you want to okay so that is
server-side rendering and let's and the
final piece is hydration so as we talked
about in the early phase we detect these
static parts inside our components in
sour component templates right so it
turns out this helps with hydration -
well we're hydrating client-side content
we already know so let's go back to the
example where we have a big giant static
tree I need to copy this a few times to
trigger the optimization so when when we
have nodes like this notice this call
creates static V node so during
hydration our client side app will match
your virtual notes to the existing Dom
nodes that's already on the page this is
caught this is called hydration right so
when we match them well notice that ok
the current V node is in fact a static
node so we there's no point in going
deeper into the tree so we'll just match
this div with this static node and we're
done
so we can skip all its
so this applies for any kind of static
tree hoisting even if it's not string
concatenation like even if it's like
this we can still skip all the internal
dissing on initial initial mount so
during hydration we'll just look at this
node adopt a corresponding node and
we're done so this the area where this
really helps is for static site
generation use cases like View press or
grit 'some right let's say you have a
huge piece of markdown as compiled into
a view component most of the markdown
content is really static so using the
new strategy most time most of the time
you just end up with the giant single
static node and the hydration process
will literally be taking zero time
because it'll just look at it and know
and know the whole page is static and it
just won't do any work so this is
another area of big improvement now
further possible improvement that we can
do is when we have cases like this the
challenge here is we don't really know
if this piece of content may get toggled
or not so in a static site generator
like View press there are some
assumptions that we can make we know
when the page is rendered the content
will always be there and we know that
the content will only be switched or
toggled when you switch routes so with
this kind of constraints in place there
are situations that we can simply say
create static node and this will be
empty because this content will already
be on the page there's no point in
sending the same content twice to the
client so your JavaScript bondo anxiety
JavaScript and unhide raishin this node
will pick up the corresponding content
from the HTML markup instead of having
to duplicate it inside JavaScript so
this will allow us to ship even leaner
JavaScript bundles for static site
generators there are some of interesting
things that you need to do inside at the
framework level to make this work
properly but I think we can make it work
for example in view press
so that you will end up with very lean
JavaScript bundles and very very
efficient hydration process so this will
make it effectively probably the most
efficient service our rendering
solutions today so that is for hydration
another cool point about hydration is
the hydration logic is tree shakable so
if you don't need service I rendering it
will won't even bloat your bundle this
applies for almost all the non-essential
features keep alive transition v-model
all these features if you don't use it
it won't be in your bundle as long as
you use a tree shaking capable bundler
ok so that is for hydration and SSR is
not fully completed yet we still need to
finish suspense support so suspense is
one of these new things that's probably
the only unstable part the most unstable
part of the view right now so we're
finalizing the support for suspense
instance our rendering we also want to
improve the mismatch handling in
hydration in case the rendered markup
and your JavaScript code just doesn't
match up
we need to somehow gracefully morph the
Dom to match your JavaScript and then
put the server-side rendering compiler
integrated into the SS C compiler and
then you won't have something we will
have a demo that has whole service order
and flow setup and the next team will be
busy at work integrating into next so
that's it for server-side rendering and
that's also all for today thank you
thank you so much Evan that was the what
that was wonderful
so I'm gonna keep you here because I'm
sure everyone in the audience has lots
of questions so we'd like to just ask
you some questions before we move on to
the next question
first of all I'm sure I'm echoing a lot
of sentiments here that there's a lot of
excitement for view three and this
question probably comes up a lot as to
like when can we expect you three and is
there an estimated date that that will
be released right so on the roadmap I
think we were aiming for end of q1 so
right now like to be totally honest I
think we will most likely be beta very
soon in maybe a couple weeks so whether
we can actually do a final release for
end of q1 that's debatable
because I think most the work left we
need the kind of work we want to finish
before calling it an actual release our
documentation migration guides migration
tooling and we want to also upgrade say
COI and dev tools and everything to
match that so at this stage I recall I
would say that the majority of work on
view itself of u3 is pretty much done
but we will take some time for us to
just like give us so the goal is to give
everyone a good upgrading and migration
path so that kind of work will probably
take a bit more time so I think the
safest to say is we'll definitely be
beta before end of the q1 and that is
that is to say when we reach beta the
API will mostly be stable there might be
still be bugs so the beta phase we will
encourage people to start building small
applications with it try it out
give us feedback while we work on all
these migration materials and once that
is done we will launch the new
documentation and everything that's
mostly in q2 yeah that's really exciting
can we have a round of applause just for
like
so for those of us who are really
excited to use view 3 and I like
anticipating the release of it there is
an ability for us to already start
working with that is there with you next
yeah so if you look at the view package
we already are releasing 3.0 alpha
releases we also have a working web pack
based set up that you can try things out
so I just go to the view next readme and
you'll find a link to the web pack setup
and just just clone it install and
you'll get running so there is is some
feature parity between like what we will
expect in view 3 and what view next is
at the moment is there or like the next
is view 3 ok yeah yeah so it's just a
way for you to work for with certain
sections of it like the composition API
or various part like slots and things
like that well everything is in there so
if you see something in the RFC it's
likely already in the view next yeah no
that's that's really cool um I guess the
next thing is that it's really exciting
to see that beauty has first-class type
script support because I think for a
long time that has been something that
has been a second-class citizen if you
want to use typescript it's a completely
different way of writing view so will
that mean that there is type inference
within oh you itself in fact let me show
you life done was in the back
so let me make this a bit bigger so I'm
inside inside of you next right now and
so how should I demo this let's see if I
create a demo
Dodge's file here and I say import
create app from view oh okay so um let
me import it from runtime dog because
I'm IMing a local set up and type square
only knows to pick up the definition
from that so notice that I'm using
javascript this is not typescript but
it's still telling me the [ __ ] this API
signature of the thing and in fact if I
do
oops create app it actually completes
the import for me
so cost app as you can see this is all
because we have first-class type type
definitions the source code is written
in typescript and during though every
package we generate the type definitions
for it automatically so we don't have to
manually maintain it and upgrade it on
every release and these type definitions
will get picked up by ID ease like vs
code hopefully webstorm as well and even
if you are using javascript the IDE will
still be able to leverage all these type
hints type definitions to give you Auto
completion and all that so if I say they
return a 1 and
[Music]
does this work no unfortunately if this
is a typescript file it will work so
you'll get a actual proper proper
inference here now what's good another
important thing that we want to see is
if you're using the composition API say
ref so I auto import it ref here so
counts count equals ref one count okay
so in JavaScript I of auto completion
yeah it does actually yeah so shows like
count is a ref and shows it's actually a
ref containing number type and you can
autocomplete the value here my computer
was probably just a bit slow so you can
do this and the best part is if I can
convert this file into typescript notice
that it's just valid typescript you
don't need any manual type hints for
that it just works so in reality the
code that you write when especially when
using composition functions the code
you're writing javascript in the code
you writing typescript will be 95
percent identical so that's the best
part
right first JavaScript code and types
are code in view 3 will look almost
identical second is no matter if you're
using typescript JavaScript you'll be
able to benefit from the type that
declarations so the the real benefit
when you really use typescript is like
the the actual tooling like when you
build your files it'll like catch errors
and warn you if you use JavaScript
it'll just ignore the errors obviously
right so but but overall I think like
this is much better than say say I think
this is better than a strategy that
would force you to use a syntax that's
dedicated for typescript but if you say
I want to use JavaScript you have to
like fall back to a worse syntax or
something right so I think the best type
of typescript support is that kind of
seamlessly allows you to transition
between
typescript and provides you the same
kind of benefits so I think that's the
main goal that we're trying to achieve
this would mean that you're no longer
when you write typescript because in the
past you would have to basically use a
class API in order to use typescript
yeah so the the assumption here is that
you no longer have to write it that way
or do you have you know writing it that
way if you want if you really really
like classes Kardashian is still going
to be working on class component support
but that's going to that's not going to
be the default right if you want to
start using type screw with v3 the most
straightforward way obviously is just
change your file extension to TS and you
can get going cool that's awesome
that definitely deserves a round of
applause for sure especially for the
typescript audience or people who really
like it I guess the next thing would be
that with view 3 are moving from view to
w3 one of the big things was the
introduction of RFC's and that allowed
the community to be more involved in the
process of understanding what was
happening how features were being
implemented and so on how do you feel
the success of that has been overall as
you're working on view 3 have you
actually what looked at certain feedback
and taken that into the future yeah a
lot of cases I think the the whole
function API to composition API and all
that we definitely took a lot of
feedback basically scratched our ideas a
few times trying to think about what's
the best way to go forward and even just
yesterday we're still kind of having
discussions in RFC repo regarding some
of the parts about the about the
composition API then I still be some
small changes that we need to apply so
it's been an ongoing process which is
really good because uh like in the past
we've some of the things we've done in
the past is like we design a feature
we're not even sure ourselves but there
was no way for us to collect wider
feedback without actually just shipping
it but once you ship it it because
there is a lot of more inertia or
resistance or friction for you to
actually change it but having the RFC
process essentially allows us to sort of
lay it out first and we in fact get
quite some very insightful feedback
because like there are often areas like
as a developer as a single person there
are areas you usually tend to sort of
neglect during a design process and
having extra sets of eyes really helps
yeah definitely and I think that coupled
with the RFC pro or the RFC's coupled
with view next was really good because
it allowed a lot of us to work on not
just looking at what was happening but
also implementing it in our own
applications to try it actually received
tons of poor requests on the interview
next repo I think we've merged over 200
full requests now yeah and a lot of them
are like first-time contributors who've
never contributed to view - in the past
they they read the IRC they read the
codebase and they just started working
on features which is really I think that
kind of shows the success of this model
we are actually getting contributors
even if we even we didn't really like
have a very thorough guide on how to
actually work on the new repo a lot of
people just figured it out themselves
yeah I think that's fantastic and it's
it's definitely telling that it's a
pretty successful endeavor itself along
that that point I think the composition
API is like a huge difference between v2
and v3 and having worked with it and
having talked to a lot of people and I'm
sure in the community as well like in
this audience a lot of you have worked
on it like one of the biggest things is
trying to convince people why they would
use it or even just I think the general
feedback that I've gotten from people is
just oh the current syntax is great why
would I want to move to this other
complicated other thing so what is your
I guess comments or feedback towards
that particular sentiment so so
personally like right now my position is
that if you have strong preference on
which which syntax you would want to use
just go with your preference the real
benefits of the composition API really
shines when you
our authoring reusable utilities or
libraries or plugins that need to inject
external logic into your current
component and I think that's an
integration point that really works well
saying you can have components
especially say if you have a legacy to
point X application with a lot of
components already written in the
options API syntax you don't really need
to change it you can start you can still
start using say a library written using
composition API in order to use it you
just add a setup call a setup function
to your current options based component
and then just inject the stuff from the
external library and it'll just work so
there is really nothing that forces you
to migrate everything nor are there
something that prevents you from using
composition API in existing options API
code base so so I guess the the takeaway
is don't think that you have to upgrade
everything to composition API you don't
if you're starting something new go with
the syntax that you prefer for your for
your presentational components or for
your I would say feature components but
if you're authoring something that's
reusable the utility that you want to
reuse across components or a library
that you want other people to use then
you should start doing it in composition
API instead yeah I think that's a really
important distinction as well just
because from a migration standpoint
instead of I don't know pulling a
specific move where you're like we're no
longer going to support view two and
behind it's not backwards compatible and
you have to move towards it I think that
automatically loses a lot of people in
the community because they feel this
this need and rush towards moving over
and if you're working on a legacy system
or if you have a lot of code that can be
a huge endeavor and so yeah yeah yeah at
the very least you will be able to you
will be able to use the composition guy
as just a better replacement for mix-ins
that's for sure yeah so mix-ins will
definitely not be the pattern discourage
people from using mixings from now on
now that composition api is available
because it's a accurate alternative
itself thank you so much for your your
time Google we're gonna move on to the
next speaker
so you can thank you
you